[Music]
i think we can all agree that
counter-strike global offensive
is almost a perfect shooter
i repeat almost even an esport as
tried and tested as cs go has its fair
share of infuriating mechanics
overpowered weapons and game breaking
bugs things that make you want to jump
out of your chair and curse the day that
big daddy gaben was born
so today we're counting down our top 10
grievances with cs go
that make us want to scream the top 10
things that are just well
[ __ ]
kicking off our list we've got our most
controversial entry
the op
i'm actually gonna i know i know how
could i possibly be talking smack about
the mighty green
isn't it the sickest and most skillful
gat in cs go
look the sickest sure but
skillful no even after getting nerfed
back in 2015
the op is still kind of old one shot to
the chest from
anywhere on the map through armor is all
it takes to delete someone from the
server
and look no one is saying the ceiling on
this weapon isn't absurdly high
but the floor pretty [ __ ] low
this thing just thanos snaps you off the
map a little
too easily and there's pretty much
nothing you can do about it
and the pros agree they can't do
anything more to like nerf it you know
because the gun's broken like it is
it's both like fully fully [ __ ] to
think that you can not be looking and
just do this
and kill two guys he's like what the
hell man it's like it should it
shouldn't be fair
you all better smoke that mid-cross
cause for our number nine entry we're
shipping off to dust
to cs go's original dumpster fire
i'm ready to go now
what is there to say about dust too that
hasn't already been said
it is the oldest most exciting and most
enduring map that counter-strike has
ever known
as well as inarguably the most iconic
battlegrounds in the history of
first-person shooters
dust 2 is quite literally an institution
but it also really sucks sometimes
planting and under window under window
under window under
the window god damn it
kill him godfather terry he just [ __ ]
sucks
what are you doing whether you're
getting flashed into oblivion on long
desperately trying to retake b or just
want to leave your [ __ ]
spawn question is can they actually get
a kill initially yes they
it's no secret that sublime though it
may be
does too can be an absolute nightmare to
play oh back to dust2 the land of
cheaters
i you know that was my hypothesis my
hypothesis was
thus two cheaters
all right look you better start holding
an off angle because for the eighth spot
on our list
we're setting up some cheesy ridiculous
one ways the one way smoke that i'm
about to show you will land on the
window latch and will allow you to peek
through a small gap at the bottom right
part of the window
while you being in the window can easily
spot any enemies at topmit
they won't have the tiniest chance to
spot you in there hey look
i get it in a game as inaccessible as cs
go
where utility isn't just learned but
mastered
knowledge is power and creating a
situation where you can see
everything but your opponent can't see
you
is really powerful what you do you do
the smoke
you do the flash i showed you and you do
the mall of firebox and you jump just
here
you clear default and this year he
doesn't see you from ct here
and while i'm all for outwitting an
opponent sometimes things can get
downright
outrageous
oh this is dumb bro i thought you're
like seeing through the smoke
i mean oh it's not that bad yeah yeah
yo yourself follow yourself i'm gonna
throw it on top of you
make your finals ball yourself by
yourself one way lane this is stupid
okay so for our seventh spot we're
forcing up
and it'll be worth it why because you'll
have a scout
i just worked chris jay's only got the
scout though but can you finish it off
oh if he hits the head he definitely can
stay alive as well dropping into
sandwich but the push is coming down
as well as uh shut down one around from
chris j three with the scout all those
the fourth as well
look i know this one's a bit of a spicy
take but hear me out
picture a poor man's op that does
roughly 70 damage to the chest is a
one-shot head shot through
armor and has near-perfect no-scope
accuracy
all for seventeen hundred dollars but
the real kicker
is that you're a freaking speed demon
whilst scoped
watch the stick strap right here
oh my god
well it wouldn't be of the score esports
top 10 without the 1g
for our sixth spot we're talking about
well just
the confusion around molotovs in general
oh no from it no
how fast do mollies actually kill you do
they do less damage through kevlar or
not
why is their spread so inconsistent how
fast does it travel
and how in god's name are you supposed
to figure out where the fire hitbox
actually starts look i'm not saying that
mollies are overpowered per se
i'm just saying that the number of times
that i have died to one that i didn't
even think i was touching
is a lot it also feels like when i touch
one
they do a million damage and i end up
looking like this
come on
all right um
just move on just move past it [ __ ] my
life
coming in at the halfway point of our
list is a map that
also feels as if it were only halfway
finished
vertigo would you remove vertical from
the map pool yes
the map is trash remove it ah
vertigo the active duty pool's very own
a-ramp simulator
a map so shoddily constructed they
needed to fix it not once
not twice but nearly 10 times after
reworking it midway through
the stomping grounds of one don hatchi
himself
and bane of professional players
everywhere
closer and closer to overtime
the first player to fall on land look
i'll be honest i like vertigo and i
still think it is a cheesy ridiculous
hellscape where mid control doesn't
matter
and you don't go b unless you have a
death wish they're holding for this
mid play with the the boost or they're
going to go for the run boost it has to
oh
no rip shakes he's annoyed about that
one giving away his life
okay look if you're even remotely
serious about cs go
you had to know that this one was coming
taking the fourth spot on our list
is the patently busted hand cannon
that is the deagle
the fact that it can end someone from
across the map with a single headshot
is fine that's what it was designed for
the issue
is that it's also god tier at close to
mid-range with two shots to the body
through armor
sealing the deal this isn't exactly what
i'd call
difficult to master up in main is the
call they're going in although and it's
robs who's found them all
only a deagle required straight to the
belt
two clicks a piece easy as that
i don't give a [ __ ] how sexy or skillful
y'all think it is
a 700 sidearm has no business being
this spammable and destructive
eeking our way into a close third we've
got a good old-fashioned classic
our game's one and only titular
annoyance getting
cs goad
what what
what
i'm talking of course about those
monitor smashing moments when
after catching someone off guard and
placing your crosshair smack dab in the
middle of their noggin
you pull the trigger only to find that
csgo's
shitty servers and spaghetti code had
other plans
he still manages to deny the plant
though blast but gets dropped and
olefmeister now
trying to find a way over here pronax
has managed to spot it
what how is that not a kill he looks
dead on there
salvaging the previous rounds doing
automatic will be boosting up the hooks
thanks decent incendiary all the bug
cs goes at its finest yep losing a gun
fight
is one thing but getting deus ex maki
knowned by big daddy gaben himself
there's just no recovering from that
it goes without saying that cs go is in
no shortage of idiots who use wall hacks
but our runner-up spot on this list goes
to the times when cs go decides to give
the
average innocent player some wall hacks
of their own
i'm actually france
dude i'm actually [ __ ] dead what the
heck
counter-strike has had plenty of
see-through smoke bugs over the years
all thanks to the source engine and the
game's notoriously nonsensical code
the problem is more or less the source
engine source is really bad at handling
multiple transparencies
layered on top of each other both the
semi-transparent smoke
and fire could be the reason why the bug
exists
if you've put any amount of time into
counter-strike there is a
very decent chance that you've smoked
off a choke held it for pushes
and watched as the enemy becomes
perfectly visible through your utility
too long one dead
that's clipped i gotta clip that like
right now
that's i'm sending that to csgo at csgo
on twitter because that's their games
bugged
now to be fair a ton of these smoke
screw-overs have been ironed out over
the years
that said you can still occasionally
spot dudes through a bloom
if there's an active molly behind it
which like
is a pretty scummy way to secure a frag
still it's not as if you're not gonna
shoot the guy
cs go is a hard game we take those
taking the top spot on our list is the
single most
kw inducing croc of horse [ __ ] in the
whole of cs csgo
the biggest baddest most mammoth-sized
cauldron of snake oil papa gaben has
ever sold us
zack did emilio just get back banned
what what
over the years valve's proprietary
anti-cheat has proven
so incapable of removing cheaters from
cs go
that other esports have started to meme
on it
nicely played mikasa yep very well
played
oh the power shot from off screen
oh man i know people complain about vag
but my goodness the aimbot is real
it doesn't matter if you're walling
toggling or just a full blown raging
spin bot
vac is more likely to stonewall you for
trying to obs your in-game footage
than loading up an actual aim assist
okay my
this isn't working and while valve has
made several efforts to improve their
god-awful anti-cheat
like with overwatch and vacnet nothing
has worked
i don't wake up in the morning wondering
if i've been banned even after a really
cheap decouple games
because at this point i i just can't see
how i'm gonna get banned needless to say
the vast majority of cheaters in cs go
unpunished
so even though cs go as a game is really
quite healthy
and in arguably the best shape it's ever
been
be sure to steer clear of matchmaking
and
stick to face it well that's it the top
10 things in counter-strike global
offensive
that are just straight thank you so much
for watching and please let me know in
the comments if there's anything you
[ __ ] hate about csgo
see you next time
[Applause]